في مبادره جديده
تربط تخفيف اعباء الديون بشكل مباشر
بالعمل المناخي اما تسمى مقايضه الديون
بالطبيعه شهدت الغابون اول صفقه لتمويل
مشروعات حفظ البيئه البحريه في البلاد في
ابسط صور المقايضه الديون بالطبيعه تشترى
ديون الدوله من قبل بنك او مستثمر المتخصص
وتستبدل بقروض الارخص وعاده ما يجري ذلك
بمساعده بنك انمائي متعدد الاطراف بضمان
ائتماني او تامين ضد المخاطر
وتستخدم المدخرات في اطار عمليه خفض
التكلفه في تمويل مشروعات حفظ الطبيعه تضم
شواطئ الغابون ومياهها الساحليه اكبر عدد
من السلاحف الجلديه في العالم وكائنات
اخرى مهدده بالانقراض كالحوت الاحدب وسمكي
ابي منشار وذكرت وكاله انه بموجب هذه
الاليه حولت الغابون
436 مليون دولار من سنداتها الدوليه الى
ما تعرف بسندات زرق جديده بقيمه 500 مليون
دولار
تشعر السندات الزرق بمعدل فائده اقل
واجاري استحقاق اطول في حاله الغابون قدمت
مؤسسه تمويل التنميه الدوليه الامريكيه
تامين ضد المخاطر السياسيه للاصدار الجديد
من المتوقع ان يدر ذلك على خزينه الدوله
في مرحله اولى
163 مليون دولار ستخصص لمشروعات حفظ
البيئه وتنوع الاحياء البحريه على مدى
الاعوام الخمسه عشر المقبله وقال رئيس
الغابون علي بونغو ان مقايضه لحظه فارقه
في مبادرات التمويل صديقه لل في افريقيا
وذكر مصرفيون ان مجموعه من البلدان
الافريقيه الاخرى تعمل ايضا على صفقات
الديون وقابلت الى جانب سريلانكا ومجموعه
من جزر الكاريبي والمحيط الهندي ونصحت
منظمه حفظ الطبيعه وهي منظمه امريكيه غير
ربحيه حكومه الغابون بالمضي قدما بشان
صفقتها وتتوقع المنظمه عقل ما بين صفقه
وثلاث صفقات سنويا حتى عام 2030
وقدرت قيمه المقايضات الامنه بايا بعشره
مليارات دولار بحلول نهايه العقد